on this Thursday night the stunning
collapse of a crypto Empire if there's
ever a place I could be that I'm not
going to get in trouble it's going to be
an FTX the investors who trusted this
man with billions and Revelations he
failed to have any corporate controls
we're going to see a huge ripple effect
Beijing accuses Canada of acting in a
condescending manner the latest strain
on diplomatic relations
deadly missile strikes across Ukraine as
he disputes the findings of an
international investigation in Poland
and he transformed the lives of millions
a beloved mentor to athletes and
administrators alike honoring a pioneer
of a Special Olympics
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us it is
hard to overstate the scale of the
collapse and the corporate dysfunction
at a multi-billion dollar cryptocurrency
exchange FTX founded by 30 year old Sam
bankman freed has filed for bankruptcy
and in a blistering Court Document today
the man who is managing the aftermath
who has also handled some of the largest
corporate failures in history including
Enron says never in my career have I
seen such a complete failure of
corporate controls and such a complete
absence of trustworthy financial
information has occurred here work is
now underway to try to locate billions
in missing assets hundreds of thousands
of investors from celebrities to the
Ontario teachers pension fund put their
money and their trust in FTX and gaviola
has our top story on the multiple
investigations now underway what do you
think are you in you know what I'm in
FTX wants one of the world's dominant
crypto exchanges touted as a safe bet in
a volatile industry if there's ever a
place I could be that I'm not going to
get in trouble it's going to be at FTX
FTX founder Sam bankman freed was
applauded for championing the regulation
of a largely unregulated industry new
reports suggest that was just for show
he amassed incredible wealth he was the
U.S Democratic party's second largest
individual donor in 2022 heralded as
cryptos Warren Buffett just a few months
ago now drawing comparisons to theranos
founder Elizabeth Holmes whose blood
testing technology was found to be
fraudulent they took client assets and
spent it on operations and this is a big
No-No if you did this in the United
States or in Canada you'd be going to
jail bankman freed rubbed Rivals the
wrong way with his push for more rules
including binance the world's largest
crypto exchange it caused the equivalent
of a bank run on the digital asset that
FTX was using to finance its debt
binance then offered to bail out FTX The
Exchange that previously bailed out
others this summer but binance backed
away after finding an 8 billion dollar
hole without this Lifeline FTX filed for
bankruptcy in the U.S Friday and bankman
freed stepped down as CEO by Saturday
reports FTX was hacked many suspect an
inside job hundreds of millions of
dollars worth of assets disappearing
bankman freed tweeted Amia culpa saying
he should have done better is he in yep
celebrities who took Equity Stakes will
lose money Tom Brady Gisele Bundchen
among others now being sued for their
involvement institutional investors
include the Ontario teachers Pension
Plan whose 126 million dollar investment
is up in the air though it tells Global
News it represents less than one percent
of its total net assets invested in so
many companies and also had so many
companies investing in them so we're
going to see a huge ripple effect the
silver lining in all of this is I think
it did need this kind of cleansing if
you will to really catapult uh The
Regulators to jump into the hot seat and
make some decisions Canada has some
jurisdiction specific regulation but
that won't protect anyone who dealt with
FTX which is headquartered in the
Bahamas and gaviola Global News Toronto
prime minister Justin Trudeau's top
advisor on National Security is being
questioned at the emergencies act
inquiry today Jody Thomas had been on
the job for just two weeks when Convoy
protests rolled into Ottawa last winter
as David Akin reports she's providing
key testimony on why Ottawa made the
unprecedented decision to invoke the ACT
as the emergencies Act was being invoked
prime minister Justin Trudeau's National
Security adviser the most influential
bureaucrat on cabinet's decision to
invoke the Act was convinced there was a
national threat to the National interest
lack of confidence in polices police
were being stretched across the country
and the
desire to
have government policy change by force
mandates
uh there were people preparing to be
violent we saw it on social media Jody
Thomas said it was clear to her at the
time that the goal of some protesters
was to force the Prime Minister out of
his job and get the governor general to
take over the number of threats going up
against uh elected officials it was an
enormous problem and an enormous concern
meanwhile the government's top economic
planners were most alarmed by the border
blockades especially at Windsor and the
potential damage they could do to
Canada's trading relationship with the
United States that threat prompted
Finance officials to come up with one of
the most controversial powers in the
emergencies act freezing bank accounts
of Convoy participants whatever we could
do we wanted to do quickly because doing
it quickly meant shortening duration and
shortening duration meant avoiding the
worst Economic Consequences that we were
concerned about now the commission has
evidence before that these Financial
measures helped clear the Ottawa protest
but the commission has also heard
evidence that the border blockades at
Windsor Coots and elsewhere that so
clearly spooked Finance officials were
largely cleared before the emergencies
Act was even invoked Donna all right
David Aiken and Ottawa thanks a Quebec
man faces multiple terrorism charges
accused of plotting to overthrow Haiti's
government RCMP say 51 year old Gerald
Nicholas traveled to Haiti and other
Central and South American countries the
alleged he organized an armed coup
against Haiti's late president
investigators say he began plotting the
coup as far back as January 2020.
the fact that he did travel to Haiti and
to other foreign countries the fact that
he did attempt to recruit to finance and
to acquire some weapon shows that
definitely he had the plan to uh you
know basically execute this coup or this
armed Revolution if you'd like
Haiti's president was assassinated in
July of 2021 though police say Nicholas
was not involved he is set to appear in
a Quebec City court December 1st
prime minister Justin Trudeau is now in
Thailand he's expected to try to boost
trade with indo-pacific Nations and move
away from over-reliance on China but
hanging over those meetings is the
relationship between Canada and China
after that tense exchange between
Trudeau and Chinese president Xi Jinping
at the G20 meeting Mackenzie gray
reports
China's president and Canada's prime
minister a diplomatic dispute making
international headlines the
confrontation between Xi Jinping and
Justin Trudeau a rare glimpse into
Political Dynamics usually kept out of
sight
the Chinese foreign Ministry finally
acknowledging The Exchange even happened
trying to clear the air and perhaps save
face a spokesperson calling it quite
normal and shouldn't be interpreted as
president XI criticizing or blaming
anyone but that's not what the video
shows she telling Trudeau it's hard to
say what will happen
after appearing to call out the Prime
Minister for sharing details of their
talks with reporters it was read in the
face visibly again very angry and I
think he wanted to uh uh maybe not to
humiliate the Prime Minister but to send
him a clear message you know you better
behave because otherwise there will be
consequences the latest trade on Canada
China relations underscoring the
importance of trade diversification for
Canada across the indo-pacific our
exporters and our businesses depend on
the strength of a rules-based trading
system
um
today's China is not the China of the
past another point of contention Judo
raising Chinese interference in Canada
was she this week at the G20 China
pushing back calling the allegations
first reported by global news
condescending accusations stating that
it never interferes in countries
Internal Affairs I still think that
China has to to kind of be confronted by
the the sovereignty question that Canada
has to defend its sovereignty it has to
defend its national interests just like
China defends its national interests and
its claims of sovereignty as well
another reason the confrontation is so
remarkable it provides a rare glimpse
into XI jinping's personality outside
the tightly controlled public events in
China when she have yet another meeting
together Friday here at the Apex Summit
with billions of dollars of investment
on the line Donna all right Mackenzie
gray in Bangkok Thailand thanks to
Ukraine now Russian missiles hit a
number of targets including energy
networks Air Raid Sirens blasted across
the country country President Vladimir
zielinski released this dash cam video
of one airstrike in April
other missiles hit apartment buildings
and Industrial sites Russia's aim seems
to be to knock out power and heat to the
country as winter approaches Crystal
gemancing Reports on the impact of these
relentless bombardments
jumping on the bus is something Millions
do daily but in Ukraine that routine
comes with risk
when the rocket hit I was getting ready
for work with my husband thank God two
walls saved us more than 20 people were
injured after the early morning strikes
residential and Industrial targets were
hit
about an hour south in zaprizio region
rubble and bodies a horrific but all too
familiar scene
he says he heard the strikes around
three in the morning three explosions he
could tell it was nearby the men here
are asked how they survive they say
there's no option it's just how it is
air raid sirens in the capital are now
accompanied by snow and power outages
repeated Russian strikes on the nation's
power grid have left many without heat
Ukrainian officials say four cruise
missiles were shot down by air defense
systems over Kiev along with five drones
it's not just Ukraine keenly focused on
security the president of Poland took to
the site of Tuesday's deadly missile
strike in person meeting with those on
the ground at the grain facility in the
small village in the country's Southeast
Andre Duda again stress the incident
appears to have been an accident
resulting from Ukraine's air defense
system
it is an extremely difficult situation
and it is not a surprise to anyone that
there is a lot of emotion here Ukraine
disputes the preliminary findings and
dispatched its own investigators joining
polish and American Crews on the grounds
Crystal commencing Global News London
a reminder today Russia's aggression in
Ukraine dates back years a Dutch court
has convicted three men of murder for
their role in the Downing of Malaysian
Airlines flight 17 over eastern Ukraine
in 2014. the passenger jet was hit by a
russian-made missile all 298 passengers
and crew on board were killed as Mike
Armstrong reports it's unlikely those
convicted will ever serve any prison
time
for the victims families filing into
court even after a trial that lasted
more than two years there was
nervousness presiding judge announced
three men were guilty there was no
celebration only relief I feel like the
process has come to an end and it's been
very fair
and it's been meticulous and it's been
thorough the decision took more than two
hours to read the panel of Judges lays
out the case against each of the accused
and their specific roles in the shooting
down of mh-17
273 passengers and 15 crew members were
killed July 17 2014. the Malaysia
Airlines Boeing 777 was flying from
Amsterdam to Kuala Lumpur when it was
hit by a book surface-to-air missile
fired by pro-russia rebels
the accused were tried In Absentia of
the men convicted one was a Ukrainian
separatist leader and two were former
Russian intelligence agents Igor Gerken
was one of them the Court ruled he was
the highest ranking military leader in
the rebel controlled region and had
control over the deployment and use of
the book missile system a Fourth Man
Russian Oleg pulatov was acquitted the
Court ruled he was in a position of
authority but couldn't determine he
contributed to the use of the missile
system
would have been
found guilty as well but that wasn't the
case
yeah
but it feels good right now
prosecutors pulled together mountains of
evidence the panel of Judges concludes
Moscow was in full control of the region
a Russian foreign Ministry spokesperson
will only say the country will study the
decision now the three men convicted
were sentenced to life in prison but
Russia isn't likely to hand them over
meanwhile Dutch authorities are still
trying to determine who else was
involved from the person at the top who
gave the order to the person at the
bottom who fired the weapon Mike
Armstrong Global News
renewed pleased to stay home when you're
sick coming up doctors urged families to
rethink their outings as children fled
Canadian hospitals plus the female
inmate on a hunger strike to improve
conditions for indigenous prisoners
doctors trying to manage the heavy
caseload of sick children say it's time
to start reconsidering where you go and
when as Ross Lord reports experts are
pleading with everyone to take measures
to prevent the spread of respiratory
viruses so more patients don't end up in
overcrowded emergency rooms
all right sweet pea let's count to three
to her mother keeping four-year-old
Ellie Sutherland healthy with a flu shot
is crucial
all of these respiratory viruses you
know it's inevitable that the kids are
getting something right now and then I
think the shortage of the cold and flu
medications for kids is also adding to
that stress and that worry so the more
we can do to prevent those illnesses in
the first place the better we're all
going to be off I think especially with
emergency departments across Canada
understaffed and overwhelmed by
illnesses we sort of have a perfect
storm of viruses all piling up on one
another the message to parents if they
or their children feel even a little bit
unwell they should wear masks and stay
home if at all possible for heaven's
sakes for parents if you've got babies
or infants or toddlers
and you don't have to take them to the
snotty nose cousin's house to play or
visit then don't do it please just don't
do it right now don't take the chance
another part of the solution extra flu
clinics like this one in Halifax and
staying up to date on Covert shots the
uptake for both of those is incredibly
small right now in Canada boosting those
numbers could make the virus crisis
shorter but as it stands the current
crunch is estimated to last for another
two or three months Ross lore Global
News Halifax
hunger strike ahead why an indigenous
inmate in Saskatchewan has refused to
eat for more than two months
an indigenous inmate awaiting trial in
Saskatchewan is beginning the 10th week
of a hunger strike her name is Faith
eagle and she says she'll keep refusing
food until living conditions improve at
her Correctional Facility in Prince
Albert and Indigenous inmates begin to
be treated with respect as Heather
York's West explains the protest puts in
focus problems that exist in prisons
across Canada
inside these Prison Walls Faith Eagles
says she's willing to put her life on
the line we are
here this is woman has been in remand at
Prince Albert's Pine Grove Correctional
Center for more than five months
awaiting trial
but for almost 10 weeks she's also been
on a hunger strike
right now and myself there's nothing but
cold water the fence blow freezing cold
air we're locked right I we just got off
a 21 hour walk up they're all single
cells and we only get checked on once an
hour but Eagle says it's not just
conditions here motivating her protest
at a national level indigenous people
continue to be over represented in
Canada's prison system in his most
recent report the federal Corrections
investigator found that the total
indigenous offender population has
increased by 40 percent in the last
decade and despite accounting for just
five percent of the total adult
population indigenous people make up 32
percent of the prison population among
women that number is more than 50
percent there's been six indigenous men
who have committed suicide
this year alone
and we're not even done here yet that's
serious stuff Advocates say prisons are
just not equipped to deal with the
intergenerational trauma that's followed
many decades of abuse at Canada's
residential schools I know people and
one of them is my son he's 32 years old
he's in there for crystal meth and uh
when he gets thrown into a cell there's
no supports for mental health there's no
support for addictions and I feel this
happens to a lot of indigenous people
the Saskatchewan government says it's
monitoring the hunger strike at the Pine
Grove Correctional Center and while the
federal Corrections investigator has
been making recommendations to improve
the situation in federal prisons in his
most recent report he found very little
has been done it's why Faith Eagles says
she will back down
incarcerated that are mistreated that
aren't treated like humans vowing to
continue this act of protest until
conditions for indigenous prisoners
improve Heather your ex West Global News
Calgary
Special Olympics Pioneer next the man
who transformed millions of lives
receives one of Canada's top honors
Sports has the power to inspire and
unite and today a Canadian Trailblazer
was recognized for his role in doing
that Frank Hayden is a pioneer of the
Special Olympics his groundbreaking
research helped create a new world of
inclusion and Community for people who
otherwise were shot out of sports today
Hayden received Canada's highest
civilian honor Eric Sorensen reports
too much
the first Special Olympics in 1968
started a movement of inclusion for
those who had historically been shut out
from society it was the research of a
Canadian Frank Hayden who spurred that
movement he saw that children were being
held back not by their disabilities but
by society's beliefs and attitudes
Frank's research actually proved that it
wasn't the disability it was actually
lack of opportunity
and so that was really the springboard
for what today we know as the Special
Olympics movement
already invested as a member of the
Order of Canada today Frank Hayden was
invested as a companion of the Order of
Canada the highest civilian honor this
country bestows since spearheading the
Special Olympics movement in the 1960s
he has strongly advocated for the
transformative effect of sport on the
mental physical and social well-being of
people with intellectual disabilities
presented by the former Governor General
Mikhail Jean for Mary Simon who is
ailing four others were invested with
the companion of the order actor and
humanitarian Tom Jackson Nobel physicist
Donna Strickland Life of Pi author Jan
Martell and Robert stedward himself a
Pioneer in the paralympic movement as an
educator and leader promoting
inclusiveness for those with physical
disabilities they've sacrificed they've
committed they've had the right
attitudes to develop their skills in
their Sports and their success then is
you begin to see that in their everyday
way of life stedward like Frank Hayden
helped to conquer Prejudice and today
Millions with physical and intellectual
disabilities are active participants in
activities that much of the world had
always taken for granted Eric Sorensen
Global News Ottawa
that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna freeze and tonight's
your Canada is Harrison Mills BC thanks
for watching Farah Nasser will be here
tomorrow and I'll see you Saturday for
the new reality bye-bye